hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
unboxing video and this as you can see
by the title is an eye skin unboxing now
what could marcus brownlee possibly
review from eye skin well i don't need
any more skins i have a wrap so so you
know what what could i possibly review
well if you guys look at the title and
the link in the description i'm
reviewing or actually unboxing today
the iskin circulene f1
uh and if you have no idea what i'm
talking about then stay tuned and watch
this unboxing video because i guarantee
you this is a product you're going to
want when you see this come out the
package this is really cool guys so
let's just go ahead and open this right
up i can
i'm just gonna tear that open because
i'm a herculean
strength
oh yeah
so first off i have to say i have to
tell you guys i was impressed with the
shipping um i applied to be a and i
skinned reviewer on their website and
they number one responded responded to
my email promptly and number two they
sent this out uh via ups and it was
actually delivered on time actually
before on time which is why i was
impressed because ups uh from my
experience has been completely terrible
which is why i prefer fedex but you know
this it scouts me on time guys
so
a box within a bag not a big deal um i'm
just going to go ahead and
cut this box right open
so here we go
can't wait to see this
this is something i've been waiting for
for only two days but i'm happy to see
it
and here it is much smaller box than i
actually expected
so there's the iskin box and there is
the shipping information no biggie and
that's all that is in the box guys so
here
is the eye skin circulan actual box and
yes straight up these are headphones
guys i'll put my knife away so i don't
cut anything
um
but these are wireless bluetooth stereo
headphones you can see that right there
wireless headset for music on the go
great great product you guys if i go
ahead and turn this on the back you can
listen to audio from your pc or your
macbook or your computer from your ipod
um and that may or may not have
bluetooth and your phone now you guys
are like well if it doesn't have
bluetooth then how can i listen to
through bluetooth headphones well that's
what the tx is for
let's just get right into this i
actually do need my knife again
i'm just going to going to just give you
guys my first impressions of the product
as i take it out the box so pardon my
arms getting in the way but this is this
is it guys oh very very nice classy very
classy i like that right there so this
is the box they show you very clean says
eye skin on the front
and pretty much blank from everywhere
else
open this up
wow
wow
nice packaging here is the tx part of it
this is the part that you plug into your
ipod or your uh your pc that doesn't
have bluetooth and that's actually a
bluetooth adapter you guys and this is
what will allow you to listen to the
bluetooth stereo headset through the
adapter okay so it is still bluetooth if
you don't have a bluetooth device very
neat i'm just gonna go ahead and pull
this up
yeah very nice i like the packaging you
know certain companies have they just
tend to be really good with the
packaging and there's the headphones on
the back and the tx which i can actually
take out
very nice very small i like the shape
but i don't want to get too into this
this is just the unboxing video guys but
my impressions so far are positive what
else is in the box
well
if we go ahead and uh
give this a
a pull
i'll be able to take out
everything else or will i i hope i will
so what else is in the box guys we have
what looks like a user guide a user
manual and another cable
and here it is okay so if you do have a
pc that does not have bluetooth you can
plug it in by usb
plug the tx in to this and there's your
pc bluetooth very nice i can listen to
these pretty much anywhere
what else is in here
okay this is the usb cable i'm assuming
for charging which is very nice i'll go
you know go over battery life in the
review video while this video is long
okay we have a user guide and we have uh
secondary you know ear pieces and rubber
and everything else that will you know
go on the device itself so that is it
for the unboxing video guys i hope you
enjoyed and i hope you're curious for
the review video as i am i'll be using
these uh as much as possible as you know
as often as possible seeing you know
what i can find you know pros and cons
and let you guys know in the review
video so thank you for watching thank
you for checking out these videos and if
you're a new subscriber thank you for
subscribing and i'll talk to you guys in
the next video peace